alors du 13 janvier au 5 mars
vous êtes hedda gabler air d'après ipsen
sur la scène du théâtre de l'odéon mise
en scène d'eric lacascade vous est
parfaite pour faire des vagues à blain
ah oui quand-même u23 récemment il était
moins bien trouvé que vous quand même
hein je n'ai pas vu j'ai jamais vu hedda
gabler ah ben non c'est vrai j'ai jamais
vu représentés mais ça va pas ça va pas
vous mettre de bonne humeur vos la pièce
c'est quand même très très dur un oui
mais c'est vraiment une pièce
extraordinaire et puis c'est une pièce
très mystérieuse hedda gabler il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent qu'ils ont
jamais rien compris à la galère mais en
fait je pense que je ne sais pas j'ai
l'impression que depuis qu'elle a été
écrite
c'est le genre de d'héroïne ne serait ce
que par exemple dans le film de chabrol
mal me fait beaucoup penser à une
héroïne chabrolienne dans la complexité
ne fait moins peur voilà je crois qu'il
ya plus de clés maintenant pour pour
accepter de pas comprendre ce genre de
comportement et puis c'est une écriture
vraiment extraordinaire où là où
justement les mots ne sont pas réducteur
dans la mesure où ils ne sont pas
essentiels ce qui est essentiel c'est
qu'il ya c'est ce qu'il ya entre les
mots et à l'époque où ipsen l'écrit
c'est c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
c'est un peu comme si déjà il y avait
c'est un peu une écriture pour le cinéma
valette voilà qui savent assez j'ai trop
parlé là vous avez bien entendu la la
j'ai 13 janvier au 5 mars à l'odéon qui
est toujours boulevard berne l'hiver
absolument voilà merci isabelle